my Elm is a new app for Muslim kids the
app is home to hours of Muslim friendly
and Islamic cartoons and series in line
with Islamic sharia council guidance all
shows promote good morals and manners
and feature no instrumental music and no
ads and that thing is now photography
when it is an addiction but they can't
really classify it as a literal
addiction because science deals with the
empirical world our five senses
empirically so I can't really say porn
is an addiction because you know we
don't really see you know Tyra addiction
you know if you come off it you're gonna
die or stuff like that you're I'm trying
to say so and this is the sad reality
because we think that all we know to our
world is empirical you know there's no
metaphysical you know there is no
spiritual it's just you know whatever we
see and touch you know seeing is
believing that's what it is but sadly
and of 80s like some Harris and the
others have come to a realization that
there is a spiritual aspect to our life
and they have turned into spirituality
funnily enough yep anyways so today
that's what we're gonna discuss before I
start I wanna play solo so Hannah what
are the most most for the most trust or
praise of glory and gratitude belong to
him as a Muslim I'm going to be going
through five dangers that pornography
causes now today I had him miss and I
got a message from a sister who said to
me which was anonymous I said to me that
she hasn't consummated her marriage for
two years for two years she hasn't
consummated a marriage and I was like
wow you know like you know we all have
needs in an odd way and you got married
that's one of the things you know the
rights your husband owes and you also
have a as a wife is well you know it's
important for a woman to be satisfied in
our marriage married life is your by
your husband
however for two years Wow and this could
give a right to a man to ask for divorce
and if you're going through this one I
ask you to do that to find out a
solution which we try to help
system of anyways but what kind of watch
your video now this video I can see on
the screen as you can see serial killers
yep there is a documentary about this
where it shows a correlation correlation
doesn't necessarily mean causation just
because there's you know certain people
have a certain trait or certain things
that they do there can't be linked with
that so serial killers
I know them was claimed that they watch
pornography violent pornography this is
same with this guy Ted Bundy who killed
about 34 females in females yeah we're
gonna react to a video here inshallah
and what we're gonna do is we're going
to see a man who was addicted to
pornography and let's see what we can
learn from so I'm going to come straight
back and discuss the five harmful
effects of pornography inshallah stating
the relationships and sexual health
technology is giving more people mostly
men easy access to pornography local
team medical specialist Christie Krueger
look at the long-term effects on the
brain and how specialists are helping
men escape their addiction
twenty-nine-year-old gay team admits he
had a problem that started surprisingly
early I was first exposed to porn when I
was 8 years old the older he got the
more he watched 8 years old he got
exposed to pornography 8 years old now
this is reason why our sponsor today is
my M they are an a plan and I really
need to urge this your children your
kids your nephews your nieces your
brothers or sisters
what they watching can lead to us of
even on YouTube yeah one thing can lead
to another and next thing you know you
searched god knows what yet random as I
open this video there was on the right
hand side which I'm gonna blurt is a
suggestion of a popular Italian popular
product pornography actress make them
easy go search that mean easily my ear
is actually giving a platform for
Muslims young Muslims to have cartoons
which is controlled in a controlled in a
controlled environment and doesn't go
into god mode other stuff
protect your children please for the
second Ossipon alternate down
or at least if you don't want to support
it by subscribing monthly inshallah but
let's carry on because this is very
profound from videogames typography
videogames of pornography located from
with something so you could say innocent
playing to pornography the addictive
habit started affecting his adult
relationships very fundamental part of
the fields that they know attractive
enough is the problem with a partner
neurosurgeons have actually studied the
brains of people who watch porn and they
found that the brain gets rewired it's
us to crave things like pixels rather
than people anything the individual
imagines can be produced within a few
clicks and so it's that manatee that
drives this tremendous search for
variety craving that novelty can be
defined as an addiction someone that's
addicted to cocaine we may still a line
of cocaine they will want some of their
brain on functional MRI or fMRI lights
up like a Christmas tree and an
interesting study out of Cambridge
University and we've done dust identical
to cocaine with individuals that
consider themselves experts say it's not
really a true addiction people can die
if they are not weaned off drugs or
alcohol
so physiologically the same thing is not
happening when you stop a sex or porn
problem versus when you stop a drugs
alcohol problem it's two different
processes which is why we can't label it
as an addiction game stopped what take
oh forget how it kills you spiritually
your heart your brain your soul forget
it doesn't we don't see any harms in the
outside so it's okay
porn six years ago and turn back to the
internet for some help but
experts say parents it really offered
the best support after the child about
avoiding internet porn as much as
possible because what they're viewing
isn't representative of what they're
going to experience in the real world
and encourage them to form real life
healthy relationships and when they're
ready sexual relationships your special
helper now we're going to do is we're
gonna go to okay this is his name is Ted
Bundy yeah so this guy now talks about
what play devoting him killing about 34
people a serial killer this kind of
literature contributed and helped wound
and shape the kinds of violent behavior
fuel your fantasies in the beginning it
fuels this kind of thought process then
at a certain time its instrumental in
the pipe would say crystallizing and
make it and making into something which
is almost like a separate entity inside
at that point you're at the verge of the
bridge of acting out on this on this
kind of these kinds of understand that
you have gone at that as far as you
could go in your own fantasy life with
printed materials and you made it in and
then there was the urge to take that
little step big step over to a physical
it happens it happened in stages
gradually it doesn't necessarily not to
me at least happened overnight my
experience with that state photography
generally but with monography that deals
on a violent level with the sexuality is
that once you become addicted to it and
I look at this as a kind of addiction
like other kinds of addiction of
addiction you keep I would keep looking
for more potent more explicit most
miraculous signs of material like an
addiction you keep craving something
which is harder or something which which
gives you a greater sense of excitement
until you reach the point where the pen
ography only goes so far
you reach that jumping-off point where
you begin to wonder if maybe actually
doing it will give you that which is
beyond just reading about it or looking
at it guys do you hear what he's seen it
is like and studies show that it is like
taking drugs the part of the brain where
it was his dopamine lights up and this
is exactly what I said he seemed that he
wanted to he was watching violent
pornography yeah and we can argue ok
this pornography lead to you know serial
killers etc till the cows come home
ok the point here is this even if those
people who are watching pornography I'm
not going to the levels of killing
people on an epidemic level even one too
many is too much this very thing
destroys you so number one it harms
relationships there has been multiple
studies on how phenomenal an offense
relation and the findings are quite
alarming yeah now your relationship this
sister that messaged me today she hasn't
had intercourse with her with her own
husband for two years because she says
that she what she was she she gets more
gratitude from yeah she gets more turned
on from what she's watching from so
she's not finding her husband pleasing
yeah so you can see the harms in a
relationship yeah now this relationship
change there are many who watch this
kind of stuff and most of the times in
pornography it's the woman that is being
the one subjugated to assault you know
and if you think about it it's in a
context it's a woman at the receiving
end you know in intimacy it's usually
and you can talk about it you know let's
not be shy here when it comes to
religion even if a woman is sexually on
top with her husband it's still kind of
the man that's in charge so this is kind
of mirrored in telefónica the
pornography industry and you can see
woman being strangled and being
strangled there's cases of in 2017 James
Moses travel to death Hannah Pearson as
he have an addiction to violent
pornography and he strangled her to
death
st. John Maiden killed his knees T Rick
yeah by overdose no with drugs and also
Graham cow strangled to death Jane dream
Longhurst the other have Lough Swilly
something going on etc then you have
Nathan Matthews and Sean Haugh him him
and his girlfriend killed their step
sister Becky Watts and all of these
people were prone to violent pornography
yeah all of them prone to avoid a
property so what you buy the property
this what it does and the least that you
can say is that these men who are
watching this and woman as well men tend
to look and degrade women because it
dehumanizes a woman a study was done
where they showed a man a half-naked
woman and the part of the brain that is
lit up for two news got lit up meaning
that he did not even see the woman as a
human he saw her as an object so if you
think about it men who are watching this
they are not looking at females on a
day-to-day basis whoever it may be when
they walk in it could be a sister in the
car which are well they're building
fetishes
in their head they thinking I want to
act like this and hit them because what
they thinking is these are not human
yeah and this is what they're doing
they're acting it out they're putting it
into action how Brian
cannot dehumanizing them using yours
giving them wine because they are
watching this and they want that they
would pornography I'm like he said it's
not enough now they want to go out and
act it they've seen it and they've
destroyed their fitrah and they're going
out there to find their brain and lie
and G or whatever take pictures the most
in this way do y have an intimacy you
know hits him that person etc in
different ways whatever it may be
why because deep inside they've got this
thing that they've watched and they want
to relive that in real life that's the
one number two it becomes addictive so
you don't stop with one and he'd be like
no you then see what should be stanity
you you're watching pornography where
children are being abused so for example
the case of Nathan Matthews and Sean
Haugh he was watching a video progress
video called titled raping and killing
virgin girl in her own house before he
killed his own stepsister
so you can see it becomes an addiction
to the point where you have straight men
watching gay pornography yes why because
it's curiosity and there was a penis why
are they watching this if they see some
kind of a like mistresses they're like
oh my gosh I'm homosexual I'm gay and
then from there god knows what stars
number three it gives unrealistic
expectations in marriage and outside of
marriage what happens is you are looking
at this female and if you look at it
this is what is being told it's no
secret of pornography pornography
industry is just that an industry in
order to make money they make everything
look absolutely perfect as stated by
fight then fight the new drug
professional porn afters have a whole
team of people to make every detail look
perfect from directing and filming to
lighting and makeup maybe even a plastic
surgeon strong edited is strong editing
is used to when making pornography
giving viewers unrealistic expectation
of what relationships should be like
you're watching something that is not
real edited the makeup everything is
edited the woman they bring their hurt
or a man etc you start doubting your
manhood oh my gosh am I supposed to be
like that you know you have an intimacy
having you know with your wife etc yeah
you know you just probably finish in I
don't know two three minutes and then
you start talking so you know oh my gosh
I didn't satisfy her you know maybe I'm
not man enough
etc all these kind of self-doubt if
she's watch pornography she's thinking
you know what yeah you know this guy you
know he's a flippin 2-minute wonder you
know what if it may be so I'm being
realistic here yet and when he's looking
at her he's thinking brother she doesn't
know about those chicks in in the in the
videos I watched her body etc so you
thinking about how this is dead bra
that's what I'm talking about
it gives unreal exist I'm realistic
expectations which causes divorces
causes unhappiness causes god knows what
and what you do you go back to the
second point which is addiction go watch
pornography again because that's where
you're gonna get your satisfaction from
number four supporting human trafficking
these videos are causing people to be
used abused and even killed child
pornography sharpen ography it's on an
epidemic level people are watching this
stuff children being raped
females women being taken captive come
on guys this is affecting society as a
whole
and fifthly porn encourages self
gratification we live at a time when
everything fast fast food amazon prime
fast cars fast hand dryers everything is
fast what everyone we need to get it now
and that messes up with the fitrah and
what happens is when you get into
marriage etc you think oh no life has to
be like this you know I want something I
get it
it doesn't work like that and studies
show that people who have restrained
herself self discipline away from that
have a better successful life these are
the five dangers that pornography causes
brothers and sisters if you're watching
this please cut it there are solutions
don't go to places where you're alone
yeah number one ask allah subhana wa
for help repenting means your Lord is
oft-forgiving or my help me out of this
mess help me it will be a gradual
progress but the first step is that you
want to do you want to make a change do
it because eventually eventually you
will slowly and where there's a will
there's a way
believe me whether school that's what
you can you need help self courage make
to our move away stop looking at
indecent things they say the heart
doesn't desire what the eyes don't see
if you are making yourself exposed to
all of this of course your heart is
going to yearn for it and don't watch
this cause it's gonna destroy your
relationship in the future with your
wife and that's the reason why soon are
we releasing an online platform where we
will be helping everybody all that must
to have successful marriages must only
get married but to stay married I've got
something big coming up in Charlotte
bone sisters I want to thank my sponsor
my Elm a beautiful app a beautiful app
for young children do not lose your
children their future to this vile
disgusting industry which is
capitalizing on innocent people
we also react in another video to a
famous actor and her life being turned
upside down guys download the app now
even if you do not have kids support the
app let other people benefit from a
inshaallah and let us help I almost
improvisation creating this kind of apps
to help the umma from stealing from
disgusting stuff I wonder if I make my
own inshallah and I asked you guys to
download it and inshallah protect your
kids from this disaster then you're a
mana so make sure you look after them
till next time Salam alaikum